same thing with the steelers pete i'm
going to go off the run down here for a
second because this dovetails was
something i've been meaning to write at
pft based on an article from ed bouchet
of the athletic who's covered the
steelers for years right just because
ownership has said we want to keep ben
for another year and just because ben
has said i'll do whatever i need to do
they still have to do it
you still have to put pen to paper on
some type of a new deal that allows the
steelers to keep ben roethlisberger to
navigate the salary cap and everyone has
to be on board with this idea that it's
just one more year that's it right and
that's the vibe that was created last
week so until that paperwork is done
by the middle of march there's still a
chance it falls apart and the two sides
say we just can't work this out the
steelers cut him and and he see the
difference for ben if he retires he owes
them 12 and a half million if they cut
him he owes them zero and if he wants to
play for somebody else next year if the
spirit so moves him he can so until that
contract is finalized between the
steelers and ben rothersberger until
they put numbers out there that both
sides say we can live with this we agree
to this this will work there's still a
chance they're going to hit a roadblock
and uh same thing with matt ryan if the
falcons try to come to him and say we
can't have a 40 million dollar cap
number this year our total caps only 180
million can you work with us to reduce
your cap number yeah no i i agree i
don't think it's i think it'll be a lot
harder with the matt ryan situation with
you there like that i do because again
still he's playing at a very high level
and he had just left the prime of his
career big ben
i don't i think it's pretty obvious i
think you know i think even he has to
know like man the way it looked last
year
this could be this probably will be my
last year and the play wasn't good
enough last year to where i think
there'll be
even a market like there was for brady
or phillip rivers i think there'll be
too many things concerning there and he
just seems like he has no interest in
flirting with any of that i think that's
why he got out in front of this
conversation very quick and said i'll
redo my contract i think he wants to let
everybody know i still want to play hey
fans i'm here i want to play i'll play
for less and help the team out i think
he's trying to get in front of that
story right now to kind of get that
momentum behind them and if i'm big ben
and if you're realistic hey two years
removed from an elbow surgery last year
man as the season went on i wore down it
didn't look the same as i did the first
seven weeks of the year
like you got a team that's that's ready
i mean they're ready i i would be like
i'll play for five cents this year mr
rooney i got 120 million in the bank
already i want one more super bowl
chance here's five cents pay me that
this year sign some other players do
your best to make our team as good as we
can with this salary cap issue
three quick points number one
nobody wants to be the bad guy in this
divorce nobody wants to be the one who
gets blamed by the fans for it falling
apart number two they're not going to be
super bowl ready in 2021 there's a bunch
of guys that they're not going to be
able to get a lot of work back because
of the cap number three this is my own
opinion and you tell me if you agree or
disagree okay not that i need to give
you an engraved invitation if i'm going
into a season as an nfl quarterback
pushing 40 saying this is going to be my
last year i just need to step aside i
don't think that's good for anybody to
go into that because i think of brett
favre in 2010. i don't think that was
good for anybody it's better you know
everybody wants to walk away with that
super bowl trophy under their arm not
everybody's going to get to do it it's
better to do that than to have an
embarrassing final season like farv had
with the minnesota vikings i don't
disagree with you right there you're
right there is a psychological aspect
there for a quarterback to where they
can't be telling themselves it's the
last year yeah i hope big ben would
you're right and if you're put himself
in his shoes or whatever hope he's
telling himself
i think i got a few good years of
football left in me while also being
able to realize that it could be the
last year or two you're right there's a
different approach there as far as that
mindset to what you're saying where
you're going in and going all right
i'll suck it up for one more one more
year i hope i can make it through you're
right then that when you're talking like
that then it probably is time to to hang
up the cleats and only big ben can can
answer that question
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports